Hey
[Music]
our serious note to self focuses today
on supermodel Gisele Bundchen and her
new book lessons right path to a
meaningful life she talks about the
highs and lows of her journey to
becoming a supermodel wife and mother in
this note to her younger self she
reflects on life love and family in a
career that hasn't been as glamorous as
it may appear
bearsy you are 13 on a bus from your
small town to visit the big city of san
paulo for the first time
little do you know that your life would
change forever
to your surprise a model scout
approaches you because of a unique look
[Music]
it turns out the bullies at school who
tease you for being different are wrong
you won't forget being called names like
Olive Oyl by your classmates but you
will forgive them when you turn 16 you
moved to New York without speaking
English he won't be easy in the
beginning jobs are scarce and you have
to learn how to manage your money so you
can have enough to eat but you remain
steadfast and grateful don't worry
in time your hard work discipline and
focus will pay off growing up is a
middle child of six sisters you learn
quickly how to share how to honor each
other's differences and how to work as a
team and this will help you through your
journey
[Music]
you will achieve great success and with
it more pressure jealousy and judgment
will come leaving you feeling sad and
alone then a tiny dog will enter your
life she will make you feel loved and
give you strength you will name her vida
life and that is where she will be your
best friend and constant companion
through all the ups and downs the high
demands from your work schedule
constantly traveling coupled with your
desire to please everyone contribute to
you starting to have panic attacks you
will learn that by saying as to everyone
all the time you're actually saying no
to you and the people's opinions of you
often have nothing to do with you but
mostly should do with how they feel
about themselves and their own
insecurities drop the guilt relax it is
not your responsibility to please
everyone and fix everything
slow down breathe trust your intuition
and remember it's about giving and
receiving since you were little you knew
there was a higher power
we're time you will learn how to listen
to the voice within
it will also experience a deep
connection to nature and protecting her
will become a huge part of your life our
very existence depends on the health of
our planet when we healed the earth we
also heal ourselves your curiosity will
make you want to go deeper and learn
more about yourself through meditation
you'll find a quiet place you can go to
that is within you you will fall in love
get married and fulfill your dream of
being a mother funny baby girl your kids
will expand your heart in ways you never
thought possible and everyday you will
learn and grow with them you will make
mistakes this is all part of growing and
learning so don't be so hard on yourself
you don't have to be perfect you are
exactly how you're meant to be you are
enough so remember no matter what comes
your way keep living your life with love
loving yourself loving others and loving
the world you live in
keep dancing to the beat of your own
drum keep following your heart and don't
apologize
[Music]
you know what's so great about Gisele is
I follow her on Instagram so I feel like
I know she's very family-oriented area
much always see pictures of her with her
sisters her mom I don't read Portuguese
but I'm sure she's saying loving things
to them yeah it just reminds you that
some people can move on and become these
superstars but they don't forget where
they come exactly I like to when she
says saying yes to everyone means saying
no to yourself trust your English
intuition and put yourself first I also
like saying as gorgeous as she is she
has the same kind of issues and
insecurities that that everybody else
has that she's sharing with everybody
she's terrific that makes a wonderful
mom - yeah